father that was on my show Jeff right
Jeff talked about Ed O'Neill and he's
known n O'Neill since like the 70s or
80s last name
I forgot real quick here I have proof
that I sent you those text messages as I
was telling you about
let me see so this guy hold on let me
tell you the story so this guy this is
Pearson Jeff Pierce Jeff Pearson this
guy in Kansas City who's the president
and CEO of a big hospital in Kansas City
name's Bob page he texts me and he's
like my son's out in Los Angeles and
he's a musician but I told you this he's
got and I'm talking about him right now
I have I think I I think I can say all
this stuff yeah he's got a very rare
disorder where his joints dislocate at
any given time is it eller Danlos I mean
he's not here to answer that question
right now so I'm was just okay well if
it's real you have to have him on and he
is a huge fan of this show and so he
said hey will you give my son like a
little boost so I get on the phone with
him I talk to him for a while ask him
when he's a fan of what he does he's
like he's a guitar player and then one
thing leads to another and he texts me
and said dude your appearance on Bobby
Lee's podcast is one of my favorites of
the show and I said you listened to the
show
why don't you write something musically
for the podcast and they'll do it as a
little music drop or something
just to give him a boost he does it I
send it to Bobby he goes I'll play it
tomorrow the kid [ __ ] watches and
listens to your show you don't play it
and then he passed away the next day
yeah Charles page number I Charlie hey
listen here Charlie can I call him
Charlie
to solve this podcast
[Music]
I love it a lot that for you even all
great as that wrote a second one to but
now I'm selecting me as I can post it
all that stuff with a story about George
eating my burger but wholly oh oh but
did that happen in a dream in a dream
I've never actually physically eaten
your butthole why by maybe like by
accident
yeah maybe I think I was eating her
butthole when she was bent over an ear
or vagina and her butthole you know the
vagina in the butthole is like Iran not
Iran like Pakistan India yeah right
that's right right and then there's that
border where the change is right and I
was in India right it Kashmir right
right
I was looking across the border huh and
I went into Pakistan and you went I
don't know what put Pakistan the [ __ ]
right so let's just make India the
[ __ ] Iran Pakistan is delicious but
route a visa but I think it's how long
have you been here she's like what she's
shy are you shy oh yeah and I think that
eating ass is a generational thing I
think that your generation never ate us
and I think that Millennials all they
can talk about like they foam at the
mouth wanting to talk about eating ass
foam at the mouth
[Music]